ciao oggi un video grandissima richiesta
come sempre posso sempre il video che mi
chiede tantissimi questo sotto gli video
vi scrivo ti prego fare questo video
shopping inventata me lo avete chiesto
anche su instagram nelle domande e io vi
ho chiesto come faccia a farlo più
bendata magari ne sbatto agli scaffali e
in tantissimi mi avete specificato the
motion pensione da tre con l'hiv 15
trani e vitale che mi aiuteranno caso
che chicco fuori dal computer video che
facciamo qui siamo al punto su pd
inventati e poi controllavano cosa non
l'ho preso e facevano checkout
acquistavano tutto io lo farò un modo un
pochino diverso cioè lui comprenderà che
metto tutto nel carrello come youtube
transito nel carrello dopo che l'ho
applicato
e poi io non saprò cosa ho preso finché
non arriva la scatola stanno imparato
una sorta di sorpresa o mistery box in
cui ho acquistato io le cose ma non so
cosa sono forse compreso al posto brano
delusione vediamo che
qualcosa di decente in cui mette delle
cose
se volete un altro video shopping
bendata ha lasciato un bel laiche come
sempre 10.000 like sandro farne un altro
siete pronti iniziamo subito
ok allora abbiamo scelto la categoria
giochi e giocattoli come prima categoria
da cui prenderemo qualcosa quindi vado
del d'armi anno prima chicco vado a ben
d'armi si sono caricati prodotti mattino
se adesso che scendere ok amaro scendo
allora prova a cliccare applicato sì
siamo giornata pagina veniamo
trasferiscono qui dopo poco allora sì io
credo che questo lo spediscono qui
ok allora andremo
ok perfetto era tornato nella sua gara
principale scegliamo un'altra categoria
allora cerchiamo ora un'altra categoria
che categoria andiamo dritti mostra
quindi abbiamo fatto il giochetto
cartoni sono tutte quella della pasqua
non solo visto lungo lì no che noia
facciamo hobby creativi troviamo picco
invento il diamante hobby creativi
giudicare da quello che è uscito fuori
secondo me non è parte fano proviamoci
scorro si è un pò di più si nostra
storia molto allora ragazze prese perché
non riuscivo a scorrere che sta battendo
il apparenza dappertutto ok ora scende
meglio ok allora
vabbè io prendo una cosa picco a casa e
cliccato fuori il presidente aprendo in
si ascolta con il mio libro verità
centro di bellezza e morgan il resto in
mente cosa carina questo dio questo con
mano non solo è deciso
[Musica]
boh clicco figura è arrivata e deciso sì
ho cliccato non hai cliccando quello di
aiuto io che già mandato a stelle o
cliccarla è l'oggetto però non sia
aperto la pagina ricca aperto aperto
aggiunti no non mi dire niente aggiunti
noto voglio capire che cos'è esempio la
cosa che riteniamo che ok ok cosa
scegliamo ad est e non pensa certo lo so
io arredamento della compatibile
bellezza da ho visto delle cose che mi
hai detto che ti potrebbero interessare
speriamo ok sono cose di cui io non
capisco se cioè non chiesto cosa sono
tra l'altro sicuramente saranno cosa
catena vi interessano non guarda lo
posso dire che secondo me non interessa
neanche atteso e letto qualcosa tipo
bagno di paraffina son pieni di
indirizzo a permette di salire sopra mi
sa che per la manicure e applicato non è
proprio un articolo però perché no è una
sotto un sottocategoria ok tutto
categoria a scorrere scorretta ma non
fatico stava trascorrendo
sì proprio meglio ok e appiccato no ok
ma ho caricato qualcosa si è cliccato
un'altra sottocategoria quale comprava
casa carretta carretta
non dico niente di ristoro per più
veloce verso inglese allora è scelto un
articolo ha però mi e non hai cliccato
ancora subire nella casella giusta però
non ha innescato no come ha detto
cliccando comunque chiuso perché
altrimenti non potremo più so ancora
perché no che caso su tutta l'offerta di
questa terra
allora arrivò invidio più faticosa che
abbiamo messo in moto per i no no perché
c'è io ora sto tagliando tutto ma clicco
continuamente a caso e non clicco niente
e quindi non si può andare avanti allora
mi ha deciso di aprire tutte le
categorie jakupi non mi devo punto dire
la band a riguardarlo e quindi elogiato
tutte aperte queste che mi interessano e
sono i rimedi giochi e giocattoli di
giochi e giocattoli giochi di società e
bellezza quella volte compare veniamo
non lo facciamo
ok allora finendo un po prova sta
funzionando
ancora non non stai cercando da nessuna
basta non serva vediamo scendere ancora
ha funzionato sta scendendo
come berlino c'è stata ma non ho
se davvero interessanti per la lazio ma
per o per caso qualcosa
ok se in una casella però si è definito
dal voi questo sia il mio al carrello
non mi dire cos'è almeno siamo riusciti
a cliccare qualcosa aspetta dove delle
mutismo no perché diverso le stelle
teoria adesso che volete posso chiudere
questa categoria giusto per contrattare
andato aggiunto otterrà seconda è una
seconda categoria però ovviamente non ha
ancora aggiunto il pallone abbiamo
pensato c'è ancora scritto preme il
carrello perché lo abbiamo aggiunto
dalla pagina che abbiamo anche coutinho
poi dopo ok geografia tornanti si ok
questo che minano categoria giochi e
giocattoli shopping sto scendendo
no ancora non si è bloccato bravo adesso
ok facendo scendendo ok crescendo piano
piano scende veloce
oddio non che applicato qualcosa sia
cliccato però non sia aperto clicchiamo
di nuovo
ok adesso sia aperto bene andiamo con
questo sì aggiunti nomi dire niente ma
quanto pare strano che chi ha aggiornato
il quarto articolo che abbiamo messo
prima che fa il quinto quindi modo per
fare goria andiamo all'altro che
ovviamente ancora treni mostra a tema
che corona il giornale f giochi di
società ok ok allora spero che capita un
gioco che possiamo fare in due
accendendo
[Musica]
oddio quanti ricordi sono tanti giochi
carini abbiamo da piccolo a questi
giochi vecchi sono dedizione loro giochi
pesci ho cliccato ok avanti dagli altri
che dicono abbiamo si sono aggiornati
con tutti e se gli arti che ultima
categoria bellezza tante volte non sono
anche esplosioni ma se siamo così
arrivati alla fine
allora torna anche per i primi 20
prodotti erano questi quindi arrivata a
fine partita inizia arrivata fino ad
oggi sta dando la camera
no così stai andando fuori dallo schermo
la voce non lo so che come una casa dove
a questa parte vecchia casa si è
selezionato l'articolo numero 10 agenda
non l'ho aggiunto sta entrando adesso
nella pagina ok ok aspettare dovuto
vedere la finestra ma insomma sempre ci
pare trace la principale
parliamo di 7 articoli nel carrello e
ora ultima categoria la mia lista
desideri che sarà l'unica di questo che
andrà ordinare qualcosa che davvero
vogliono quindi parola messa desideri di
bella nuovamente e andiamo a prendere
una cosa assoluta la mia lista delle
ditte quello che ci metteva una giusta
chiudere anche questa volta
metti la tua lista desideri perché sono
io vedo già cosa c'è dentro ricordato
per seppi clicca le tue liste se non
vale
una scusa ha detto esiste questo sì ci
sono degli articoli si pensa sia a
destra c'è solo una tanto immaginato sei
vivo e quelle per il tris degli acquisti
ci siamo si sta scorrendo era ben
ferivano già da pin up o no ancora
adesso piano piano se il mondo dell'auto
è d'accordo chicca che scendevo combo
con questi lockley che lo mette
direttamente nella f apposta giunto a
capello ok allora ora pensare funzionerà
fare l'ordine ce lo porto io vedo tutto
e andiamo a ordinare tutto e ci
rivediamo una volta che arriva il tutto
e facciamo arrivato il bacio
che è rimasta per spacchettare viviano
in dvd in due pacchi quindi iniziamo
prima da questo forse non tutto va bene
e poi lo sapete già purtroppo ma io so
però qualcosa che chiama divertente e
carino
siccome sono tante cose faccio come la
mistery box e nei pesco uno alla volta
così non mi vedo già tutte
perché uno di quelli che ha ordinato
ribelli è una scatolina un cubo di rubik
como di rubik con le scritte in
giapponese anche qualche scritta troppo
neve ma è comunque di rubik particolare
delle istruzioni in giapponese molto
utili vabbè comunque a casa scritta
quanto ponente in italia allora ho
sempre voluto imparare a fare incubo di
ruby ci sono dei tutorial su come farlo
in è il primo oggetto voi lo sapete già
comunque che cosa avete da contenta come
sempre di un voto da 1 a 10
a ogni oggetto sia io che vuoi questo ti
do un sette giornate serio dove qualcosa
di semplice e carino ho detto che a
volte di data da 1 a 10 a cubo di rubik
ora passiamo al massimo si calcola che
ok l'altra scatola media c'è scritto
best music shop punto com
la musica quali si grazie
come scritto umano
iscritto alla sezione aia smetta quindi
c'è poco amaro pezzo di film ci sono una
grande fan di game of thrones è anche
carino mi piacciono abbastanza e
sporcano perbene sentiamo come la musica
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sia vero
pensavo fosse il bambino un match ben
cinque volte tipo e moscarino con la
fattura è fatto che sia fatto a mano di
fatto sotto più lunga ma alla fine in
carriera un piccolino quindi come queste
super contento di questo perché sono una
falla del trono di fare quindi questo ti
do un otto e mezzo tu che l'utilità
anche io se però contenta c'è una
scatola media
intanto 80 marina mentre nel corso sono
palermo a questa mamma mia moglie quindi
dalla mente di dire ma questo è
destinato questo fortunatamente non sono
affatto selezionato gli orecchini
tedesco non mi arriva e tutto il resto
fa la germania
boh questo cambia colore tra l'altro
migliore va salvato cambia colore da
viola diventa blu però non so se sia
quello che diventa slide homebrew quello
che mi metto gelatina scritto tutto
inutile allora parlò allora ci metti
moviola è solo perché ci sono due colori
il cuore blu
allo slam per davvero
sì però alcuni con lo spray martinicano
la gelatina vincolate per avevo già
fatto poi scritto sempre i commenti se
volete che faccia il bagno in questo
colore però potrebbe anche essere
gelatina in un flame
lasciate un bel like 10.000 life andrò a
fare il bagno ma contenta perché
ovviamente era nella mia lista desideri
quindi non posso non è per contenta di
averlo steso è lido non lo so perché
dovrei ancora testati conosce protette
vediamo con otto e mezzo se funziona
anche di più invece la fiducia
un oggetto che vista che l'ultimo qua
dentro
oddio con un tablet magari no spero di
no avrei perduto volta just ben
illuminate per gli stomaci cliccarvi
sopra balance una tavoletta grafica si
illumina ops troppe na rotola scaffale
vediamo le slide out
forse proprio pannello per ricalcare
forse il pannello quindi io da tanto con
il disegno però magari con questo cioè
cominciò ad nvidia ci sono i primi e
sottilissimo troviamo devo prendere
avete mai hanno fatto una cosa del
genere capace come funziona magari
rifargli il tempo è una grande soluzione
per animatori designer e enthusiast in
parte dei disegni velocemente e
facilmente si pensa che sia per
ricalcare non mi divertivo quando si
fanno gas con animali che ci sono
diverse immagini quindi una parte del
corpo la puoi già ricalcare poi l'altro
la modifica da quello che abbiamo capito
sono per animatori o per disegnare sumo
ricalcare i disegni te quindi forse lo
regalerò un fratello che non animatore
ma vediamo prima o magari notato come
lampada in chiave sono bellissima luce
va beh la sezione non si vede bene
dobbiamo provare a mettere un foglio e
non di tentennamento ma fatemi vedere
fateci sapere se volete che provi a
ricaricare qualcosa con questo favoletta
magari se siete interessati anche voi
perché volete di segnare 40
o fare fumetti qualcosa del genere
fatemi sapere se vi interessa l'ump
rombo beh questa era la prima scatola
che ho avuto dopo ecco l'idea perché
l'autore testare prima pentro impegnare
le animazioni sono ridotte di zombie
sette e mezzo a me non so se sarà molto
utile
secondo me potrà fare la sto vedendo più
con una luce aggiuntivo agli ingaggi più
di 23 già un otto e mezzo quattro e mi
diverto troppo sembra che siamo a natale
con mio compleanno vip l'angolo perché
non mi regala niente nessuno
un'altra werther allora mettono mano
dentro sempre un cazzo sono cose più
grandi mi sembra parto dalle cose più
piccole
bottiglia la crema solare protezione
molto alta spray militante effetto pelle
asciutta 50 più fantastico questa
utilissima perché noi siamo bianchicci
quindi abbiamo bisogno della protezione
solare sempre molto alta sì infatti
queste finissimo per contenta che fa
capire che su questo oggetto non lo so
dobbiamo farla testarla ma questa non è
extra i no non estrae prima sette e
mezzo 8 dell'eni coinvolte da un pezzo
di carta
[Musica]
eccolo prima qualcosa dentro la busta si
sono creati per i castelli quasi ci si
avvicina così per togliere gel ma sono
sporchi cioè sono sporchi ma a manca
questa combini che stavano veramente
veramente poco però si sono messi male
tosti e anzi oggi attività è utile
perché uso lo shell
ma la qualità c'è chi c'è la carige per
le unghie
la qualità è terribile cioè sono sembra
che siano stati usati da qualcuno
guardate dei segni stravinse sono stati
e saremo sempre noi
vabbè questo ha detto non può delusione
5 tutti gli altri hanno fuori questo
bagram
ancora grande attenzione un certo bene
non potrà se non stata ben altra star e
recitazione un atto tanto così stupida è
un bambinetto tu devi creare di quel
caso è visto fare nei commenti se volete
vedere io venissi si può giocare ma di
sapere se volete che io in vita le
facciamo un video assieme in cui
proviamo questo cammino se metteremo un
ciclo nuovo gioco per non lini abbiamo
inventato tutto ci manca solo che
cardine per questo gioco questo gli
siamo molto divertente dobbiamo ancora
provarlo magari invece dell'acqua del
gabinetto perché lo investe di
metronapoli magari su i tunes line
qualcosa siete giustificare il budget
perfetto quindi miracolo dopo diritto
per i commenti due volte che
affrontassimo come questo dove la nella
stazione di trucchi non le primo è il
primo che ha scelto mi sa che era non
ricordo
si precisa che la gioia stazione che
sicuramente con i buchi sera consiglia
comunque non me perché va beh ci sono
dislike qua si chiama laboratorio dei
fluidi schifosi e diverte ma perché
chiamano stupidi schifosi queste multi
che creano questi giorni hanno capito
che gli impieghi sono fantastici non
sono fluidi tipo di gelatine schifose
sono bellissimi si intendono mai provato
uno di questi kit g kit che fanno gli
slime quindi fatemi sapere magari io
vitale li proviamo insieme però magari
possiamo aggiungere un conduce oltre a
provare di troppo aprirlo e provarlo
faretra tutta penitenza oppure la sfida
di chi lo fa meglio io lui oppure la
sfida in 30 secondi nei commenti i
vostri consigli non è cosa sia forse ci
sia davvero l'acido borico bene ragazzi
questo è il tutto sono super contento
pensavo che avrebbe subito solo con lui
non me ne fregava niente ma
fortunatamente amazon
penso che comunque come conosca già i
miei gusti
i cookie e sono qualcosa del genere sono
rimasta molto contenta delle cose che un
freddo trova ovviamente per anni questa
ma quale fate invito a farvi come se
volete vedere un altro video come questo
e anche quale volete più gruppi di
questi quattro cartellini che potete
cliccare per vedere i prossimi video
soprattutto vedere i nostri video
shopping o l'unboxing video divertente
in uno speciale casco che preferite e
buona visione
ciao